the United States now has close to a
million confirmed cases of Cova 19 and
over 55,000 deaths much of the country
remains under lockdown and protesters
are taken to the streets in multiple
states to voice their anger over what
they see as an infringement on their
civil liberties and ability to make a
living now at some point as deaths from
the Cova 19 pandemic start to decline
and the country is able to get back to
work
economies will reopen but if that
reopening isn't done thoughtfully or
carefully it risks a second wave of Cova
19 infections and the question is what
would that look like from both a health
care and economic perspective dr. Rafael
Amaya an associate scientist at the
Johns Hopkins Bloomberg School of Public
Health says part of what is needed to
reduce the severity of a potential
second wave of infection is to establish
a medical surveillance system as states
open back up there has to be a
surveillance system that is able to
detect and then able to identify
positive cases so once they're
identified those folks can be
quarantined and isolated and then there
also has to be contact tracing and
unfortunately we're just not there yet
in the United States and that is the
biggest issue is that if we had us a
more robust surveillance system then we
might be able to manage it but we're not
there yet
dr. Lamia says that a big challenge from
Kovan a team from a public health
perspective is simply there are many
things that researchers don't know and
that makes it difficult to determine
exactly how states should open back up
their economies my suggestion would be
to do somewhat of a phased approach part
of it would have to look at what does in
each state because as you know each
state is on a different curve so looking
at each state looking at the number of
cases that the state is essentially
confirming every day once that we make
sure that that bell curve is way way
down not just starting to peak and going
down
that we know that there's less virus
circulating within particular states
then we can start to slowly open things
back up and by that my concern is that
because people have been stuck at home
that as states start to open back up
it's gonna be a little crazy that people
are gonna go out and are gonna want to
do everything and again I feel as though
maybe it should be a bit of a staggered
approach that first let's think about
you know opening parks
I don't know right and kind of then in
another couple of weeks again looking at
the cases looking at what's happening
and looking at the data then maybe we
can open up other things slowly slowly
slowly so if a second wave of infection
does occur and it causes an additional
set of economic damage
how might Congress be able to respond
here are some thoughts on that from
Forbes staff reporter Sarah Hansen who
covers money in finance the government
cannot the time will come when we have
to reckon with how much spending the
federal government does when it comes to
programs like the PPP and you know most
people expect that that reckoning will
come in the form of taxes down the line
for the first time in decades the
federal debt is projected to be larger
than the entire economic output of the
United States so there's no there's no
doubt that we're spending a lot of money
and there's also no doubt that you know
one day down the road we'll have to
reckon with that spending
you